the US is in the red tell you something
you don't know will the black widow
spiders neurotoxin is 15 times more
potent than that of a diamondback
rattlesnake so there won't be a video
next week my brother's getting married
and I'm the best man lots of stuff to do
but everybody wants to talk about the
debt ceiling do we raise it do we not
raise it who's to blame
yeah let's forget about all this
political football for a second and ask
ourselves why were even having this
discussion we're in this mess because
the federal government has literally
acted like a real-life equivalent of
dumb and dumber where's all the money
that's as good as money sir
those are io u--'s we're spending money
we don't have on things that we don't
need okay just get the bare essentials
this is the last of our dog bailouts
alone are projected to cost the federal
government over 23 trillion dollars
according to Politico and I want to
address something here I constantly get
emails saying yeah but what about your
wall street Republican buddies you
supported bailing them out firstly
Republican Democrat I don't care if
you're a conservative and you support
any bailouts you're doing it wrong and
then a minimum cost of 25 billion
dollars according to the CBL likely more
I hate the Wall Street bailout more than
most
which reminds me conservatives if you're
money manager or financial advisor
supports the Wall Street bailout you
need to drop him like a bad habit
because he doesn't share your values
well I sat down with someone much more
qualified than I mark Madson with two
point seven billion dollars under
management with Matson money and he had
this to say Wall Street bailout what do
you think it was joke it was a scam only
American people it was nothing but crony
capitalism you know as conservative of
my principles are you know you have to
be real when you're talking you know I
was fortunate enough to interview John
Boehner before he was elected Speaker
and you know he sat right here where
you're sitting and I asked him what
about the bailouts and he says well we
had to do it you know we just we didn't
like it but we had to do it well why you
know first of all it's immoral the you
know capitalism works
because you allow companies to evolve
out of the system they said well it was
too big to fail whoa that's garbage to
the West Indies trading company was the
largest company in the world like the
employ to bid through the whole
population of the world they had their
own army for 200 years they made 18
percent on their on their money for
dividends they went bankrupt no company
is too big to go bankrupt and the lie
was that if you bail us out we're gonna
save the whole system so I have
Mainstreet bailing out these people who
mismanaged their business model they
should evolve out of the system make
room for capitalists and entrepreneurs
who understand risk so they can maximize
wealth and you know but I know that it
saves us a to know we'd be an 18 percent
unemployment if we hadn't done it that's
why I did the calculation it's really if
we hadn't done it would be at 6.4% point
four percent exactly or three close
somewhere in there that's about what I
figure there's pretty much the same
number I had it's funny we must be using
the same algorithm guy so I really want
to know folks what do you think of this
whole situation is the spending
necessary do the bailouts help anything
let me know and I want you to think of
auto manufacturers airlines banks all
the too-big-to-fail entities versus your
local restaurants grocery stores malls
and ask yourself where you're more
likely to be satisfied as a customer
with their services hint a never-ending
supply of federal bailout cash
regardless of profit isn't really the
breeding ground for performance-based
business models and at the end of the
day the United States has no more of
this and these are maxed out so you try
going to a restaurant that way pay your
tab and see how it pans out for you